Такого "коктейлю зброї" не має жодна армія світу.
Від броньованих "складників", на кшталт, "Леопардів" та "Челенджерів",
до важкої артилерії, "приправленої" реактивними системам залпового вогню.
За понад рік повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну свою зброю Україні
надали понад два десятки країн - від держав ЄС до США та Австралії.
Ось основні види озброєнь, які ЗСУ готує для контрнаступу.
Бойові танки "Леопард" мають бути в основі "залізного" кулака,
що прориватиме оборону російських військ та звільнятиме окуповані території.
"Леопарди" мають різні модифікації. Серед тих, що отримали українці,
є оснащені тепловізорами та сучасними системами управління вогнем.
Серед озброєння - 120 міліметрова гармата та два кулемети.
Британці ж надають свої основні бойові танки "Челенджер 2".
У них така ж гармата і два кулемети.
Дальність стрільби - до дев’яти кілометрів.
Також ЗСУ мають отримати американські "Абрамси".
Орієнтовно це відбудеться наприкінці року. У них найкраща броня
та системи управління вогнем.
Цей французький AMX-10 - фактично два в одному: і танк, і гармата на колесах.
Через доволі потужну гармату його іноді називають "колісним танком",
але рівень броні значно нижчий, ніж у танків. Це бронемашина
в основному для бойової розвідки. Вона надзвичайно мобільна і тиха.
Розганяється до 85 кілометрів на годину та може пересуватися на одній заправці
на відстань до 800 кілометрів. Це вдвічі далі, ніж звичайні гусеничні танки.
Також зіркою серед західних БМП є німецькі "Мардери".
Це бойова машина піхоти, яка забезпечує доставку піхоти та вогневу підтримку.
Marder може вмістити у собі 6-7 бійців.
Він оснащений 20-міліметровою автоматичною гарматою,
а також опціонально керованими ракетами проти наземних і повітряних цілей.
А це американський Bradley. Він став одним із найулюбленіших бронетранспортерів у світі.
Bradley використовували у всіх великих військових операціях США,
включаючи війну в Перській затоці 1991 року та війну в Іраку 2003 року.
Самохідні артилерійські установки відіграють одну з вирішальних ролей у цій війні.
В артилерійських дуелях з військами РФ беруть участь найсучасніші західні системи.
Зокрема, німецька Панцергаубиця 2000, яка поєднує в собі живучість,
мобільність та високу скорострільність. Дальність вогню - до 50 кілометрів.
Гідний аналог - французький "Цезар". Ця САУ теж вважається однією з найкращих у світі
і добре себе зарекомендувала під час боїв в Україні.
Також на передовій воюють польські "Краби", словацькі "Зузани",
британські AS-90.
От-от мають надійти й шведські "Арчери".
Не менш важливими для комплексного бою є і причепні гаубиці.
Зокрема, ось ця - "три сокири". Так прозвали українці одну з найбільш
поширених гаубиць в армії США М777.
Її можна розгорнути для пострілу за шість хвилин.
Крім того, вона може стріляти керованими снарядами "Екскалібур".
Це збільшує дальність точних пострілів до 40 кілометрів.
Також на передовій працює легка британська гаубиця L119.
Італія голосила, що готова надати також гаубиці FH70 -
це спільний проєкт Італії, Великобританії та Німеччини.
Західні реактивні системи залпового вогню багато в чому змінили хід бойових дій в Україні.
Передусім це HIMARS. Тут шість реактивних снарядів.
На відміну від радянськи х РСЗВ можна максимально точно
наводити кожну ракету. Тож акцент на конкретних цілях,
а не просто накрити певну площу, як це роблять "Гради".
А це М270 - система залпового вогню на гусеничній платформі.
Не така маневрена, втім більш прохідна і має вдвічі більше ракет - 12.
Воює Україна й модернізованим за часів Чехословаччини
варіантом "Градів" - системою залпового вогню RM-70 Vampire.
Зенітно-ракетні комплекси - один з ключових елементів
протиповітряної оборони України. Саме завдяки ним російська авіація
не може спокійно почуватися в небі і не здатна задіяти весь свій потенціал.
Німецький зенітно-ракетний комплекс IRIS-T - один з найсучасніших у світі.
Навіть Бундесвер ще не має його на озброєнні, а в Україні вже є.
Його використовують для захисту від крилатих ракет, безпілотників,
літаків та гвинтокрилів. Крім того, є норвезько-американський ЗРК NASAMS,
італійський Aspide,
французький Crotale,
німецький Gepard.
Найближчим часом має надійти й основний зенітно-ракетний комплекс
американської армії PATRIOT, який вражає цілі на середніх та великих висотах.
І не лише літаки та крилаті ракети, але й балістичні ракети,
які зараз недосяжні для української ППО.
Крім того, західні партнери постачають Україні ударні безпілотники,
протитанкові ракетні комплекси, сучасні міномети та гранатомети,
ракети і снаряди, стрілецьку зброю та амуніцію.
Військова допомога вимірюється мільярдами доларів.
Поки що в переліку немає західних реактивних літаків, на кшталт F-16.
Але Україна наполегливо працює над цим із західними партнерами.